vous dire madame la ministre à la fois
ma tristesse
et
mon étonnement de voir que ce que le
gouvernement a accepté par exemple il y
a trois mois ennemi bientôt pour la
durée de vie du pass sanitaire îlots
refuse pour les mois qui vont venir mais
qu'est ce qui a changé
dans les déterminants de la position du
gouvernement
je ne peux pas réussir à croire
que c'est la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle qui pourrait vous arrêter
car puisque nous avons ici démontrer
notre esprit de responsabilité
nous n'en changerons pas et puisque nous
avons démontré également que nous nous
inscrivions dans une cohérence et
continuité des positions du sénat nous
n'avons aucune raison de changer
d'attitude par contre vous vous avez
changé de position et ceci est pour nous
une
question essentielle puisque derrière
votre intransigeance
derrière la fin de non recevoir
que vous nous opposer il y a
nécessairement pour nous le soupçon que
des intentions politiques aient pu être
présente dans une position qui n'est
plus la même que celle que vous avez
accepté à la fin du mois de juillet 2021
à la tristesse s'ajoute donc que
l'incompréhension et le mécontentement
face au non respect de principes
fondamentaux de nos institutions
démocratiques et c'est la raison pour
laquelle madame la ministre nous
réitérons les positions que nous avons
prises et nous ne pouvons pas admettre
qu'il n'y ait pas eu de discussion car
cette discussion les députés nous l'ont
dit c'est vous vous gouvernement qu'il
l'avait en réalité interdite ce qui est
déplorable